[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute geht es wieder ein leckeres
gericht also einen hauptgericht aus
einer pfanne oder aus einem topf und
zwar habe ich heute wieder einen nudeln
rezept dieses mal mit linguine nicht mit
spaghetti aber es sind auch solange
nudeln und ich werde jetzt den rahmen
machen also sowieso wie hähnchen rahmen
geschnetzeltes mit business model und
mit spinat und ich zeige mich jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten aber das sind
jetzt halt nur zutaten die ich
vorschlage ihr könnt natürlich auch ein
bisschen variieren was anderes nehmen
ich brauche etwa drei esslöffel mehl
hier habe ich 350 gramm hähnchen innen
viele eine zwiebel 2 knoblauchzehen 100
gramm sahne
hier habe ich ein päckchen linguine ich
brauche aber nur 350 gramm hier ein
bisschen tiefkühl spinat das sind so
etwa 150 gramm salz pfeffer etwas
olivenöl und ungefähr 700 milliliter
wasser und ich kann jetzt schon mal die
pfanne erhitzen
ich mache das nicht wie beim letzten mal
bei beidem tomaten rezept aus also ich
mache es zwar schon aus einer pfanne
aber nicht in einem durchgang als ich
mir rat jetzt schon vorher dass
hähnchenfleisch an mit den zwiebeln weil
ich einfach diese röstaromen mit drin
haben möchte es gebe ich hier schon mal
drei esslöffel olivenöl rein und kann
deshalb schon mal die zwiebel fein
schneiden oder fein hacken
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich die zwiebeln
gemeinsam mit den global vierteln in das
heiße fett das ist jetzt nicht zu heiß
also ich habe es nicht auf höchster
stufe
und während das hier so vor sich hin
dreht das trifft schon richtig lecker
also ich find knoblauch ist eigentlich
so nach zitrone der beste geruch in der
kirche naja zumindest bei hertha jetzt
kann ich schon mal hier das fleisch
klein schneiden
auch meine augen und da ist jetzt ganz
wichtig wenn jetzt das fleisch auf dem
brett schneidet das ja dann sonst nichts
mehr darauf schneidet einfach wegen der
hygiene
ich schneide das jetzt so in
mundgerechte stücke also circa 12 cm
groß
und dann gebe ich auch hier direkt das
mehl oben drüber damit das hähnchen
sowieso benetzt wird damit nicht
komplett weil dein recht geben wir dann
gleich mit in die pfanne und jetzt ruhig
hier die zwiebel noch mal ganz kurz
durch die sind jetzt schon seit etwa
eine minute da drin
es kommt auch direkt das fleisch mit
rein und jetzt entferne ich eben alles
was mit hähnchen in kontakt waren also
einfach wegen der hygiene jetzt
[Musik]
mit frage ich das hier alles ganz scharf
an als ich habe trete wieder ganz hoch
gestellt es gibt auch das restliche mehl
betreiben nicht alles ich glaube ich
habe ein bisschen zu viel abgemessen bis
anbraten und jetzt kommen alle anderen
zutaten zuerst mal die note wie gesagt
250 haben es reiche also für etwa vier
personen
sie breche ich einmal durch die pfanne
passen wir sonst nicht rein
dann fühle ich da schon mal etwa 400
milliliter wasser rein aber mehr als 500
milliliter ich bin auch schon mal mit
pfeffer und salz
[Musik]
und bevor jetzt die sahne mit der zug
bekommt erstmal deckel drauf in etwa
einer minute zehn minuten so ein
bisschen weich dann kann ich alles mal
durchführen
und ich merke auch jetzt schon dass die
flüssigkeit auf keinen fall erreicht
deswegen gebe ich noch ein bisschen was
da mit rein und den rest fühle ich jetzt
aber auch schon mal mit sahne
ich habe jetzt die hitze auf etwa
mittlere stufe gestellt
und lass das jetzt mal so fünf bis
sieben minuten lange köcheln
dann höre ich immer wieder auch mal
durch so etwa alle fünf minuten und dann
schaue ich einfach mal die konsistenz an
wenn die nudel noch zu fest sind kommt
noch bisschen wasser mit rein wenn sie
schon durch sind also al dente sind
könnte auch den deckel unternehmen und
später geben wir einfach noch die sich
von dem spiel nach mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt nach fünf minuten ist die
flüssigkeit fast komplett eingezogen
und ich gebe jetzt den spinat man dazu
das ist ein tiefkühl spinat und die
haben ganz viele wasseranteil mit drin
deswegen lasse ich den jetzt erstmal mit
reingeht ein bisschen wasser noch dazu
damit ist unsinnig anbrennt
und jetzt gebe ich den deckel drauf und
lass' es nochmal so etwa zwei minuten
eben einen ziehen vor allem löst sich
dann der spinat bisschen auf der haut
auf und dann sollte das gericht sogar
gleich fertig sein
mein nudelgericht ist jetzt fertig bei
mir hat es etwa 15 minuten gebraucht
aber es kommt natürlich auch darauf an
was für nudeln ihr benutzt also die
linguine die ich hatte
die brauchen so etwa elf minuten bis der
al dente sind falls es spaghetti nimmt
brauchen wir etwas kürzer eventuell bist
einfach mal auf der packung schauen und
einfach zwischendurch einfach mal
probieren so habe ich das gemacht auch
das glaub ich vergessen und ich habe
jetzt hier noch ein paar frische kräuter
von der terrasse für unserem kräuterbeet
bisschen basilikum etwas oregano gebe
ich jetzt nämlich auch mit rein ist dass
ich zu mir 'du ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich kann oregano thymian majoran
bohnenkraut nicht auseinanderhalten ich
finde die sind für mich viel zu sehr
verwandt und ich erkenne am geruch gar
nicht mehr also ich weiss 1 wild 1 ist
nicht wild und ich erkenne das nicht
mehr so aber ich finde es schmeckt mir
natürlich auch alles gut das hab ich
jetzt ganz kurz und es kommt jetzt hier
mit reinkommt wie jamie oliver von
wersch meist immer alles einfach so weil
es richtig richtig gut dass es bei ihm
sieht es ganz gut aus wenn das macht
aber ich mag die sauerei aus
[Musik]
und falls euch aufgefallen ist habe ich
heute gar kein chili bin ich finde das
passt heutigen wir haben ja ich mache
mir schon auf und teller aber ich finde
so dieses grün das harmoniert jetzt
gerade so schön
also ich finde kate ist jetzt auch jetzt
ist man es mit super ich weiß es gut
schmeckt aber würde ich anstatt der hypo
ist es jetzt auch gambas in den kanister
richtig lägen im januar stehe ich mag
nicht so gern meeresfrüchte in der
türkei habe ich jetzt war schon ein paar
mal gegessen aber auch nur weil sie doch
ganz frisch sind aber ansonsten mag ich
nicht
so hat man probiert teller für dich du
weißt dass du wieder da foto teller ja
so der große partner in die spülmaschine
und ich möchte eine zweite da spüren
deswegen und hier kommt noch etwas
parmesan darüber
ich liebe sie noch richtig
das ist also es geht auch paul sand aus
der tüte das geht gar nicht sie absolut
studieren und ich denke hier noch kurz
fertig übrigens lager ich den immer im
kühlschrank und zwar in einem
geschirrtuch weil dann wird er nicht
feucht und schimmelt nicht denn wenn man
ihn in seiner box verstaut da ist dann
alles dicht dann besser die feuchtigkeit
raus und dann wird er eben schon nach
kurzer zeit
und ja wirklich extrem
ich meine ich weiß ist es wirklich super
die würze immer ein bisschen mit salz
noch genau als ich mache das immer
lieber etwas weniger
jeder kann selber nachwürzen und ich
finde das gericht einfach super lecker
vor allem diese wallpott rezepte sind
natürlich auch zum beispiel was für
studenten die eine kleine küche haben
wollen nicht viel geschirr spüren nur
eine pfanne die man dann später
abwaschen muss und auf jeden fall geht
es ganz schnell und hat ganz wenig
arbeiten ja also ich finde auch diese
wort rezepte richtig genial
und wenn ihr dieses rezept nach macht
freue ich mich es steht nochmals alles -
blog.de und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder
guten appetit